people bs themselves they say to
themselves i'm going to game the system
i'm going to tell everybody that if they
buy a pair of socks from me
i'll give a pair to charity i'll get
lots of free press
the buyers at walmart will want to see
me because i'm doing something good
and i'll actually stay in business even
though my costs are twice as high as my
competitors you've got
you know what i'm talking about i'll
tell you i have a problem with it or
whoever is doing that as part of their
business i have a problem with it
because it's [ __ ]
there is a growing sense
i think maybe partly driven by the
the business interests or the consumer
interests of
the millennials that
it is part of a business's
calling to either give something back
to do something good to have a bigger
social purpose or impact
than merely to make money for
the founders and the shareholders
it's a huge debate in america it's a
huge debate in this room
it's a huge debate in every graduating
cohort of engineers in america
it's a it's a global debate going on now
i think there are some issues here and
i'll explain what they are
the backbone of success of of our
country in capitalism
and the most noble thing you can do in
your life
in my opinion is to start a business and
create a job
there is nothing more noble than that
but when you take on that journey you
also after you hire your first employee
and have your first customer
and your first shareholder is you have a
responsibility of sustainability
of the business because you're now
servicing customers
you have employees that were that
actually
that you're responsible to maintain
their jobs their standard of living
their ability to have a family
comes from you now when you introduce
a new mission because the primary
mission of a business
is to take care of its customers its
employees and its shareholders
that is the dna of business
when all of a sudden you introduce a new
cause and let's just make it generic
we're going to save the world whatever
that means to somebody
you cause a mutation in the dna of the
business
now you could say going to the darwinian
theory that mutations create success
that you morph into something that's
very successful
and there are analogies in business
across
multiple sectors shoe companies other
companies that bring a cause
into the model and it's very successful
because it's a connection
to the customer in a way that's unique
if you can sustain that you have brought
it into the marketing aspect of what you
are to your customer
and you built it into your income
statement and it allows you to remain
competitive
and raise capital against your
competitors and you found a way to do
something that they didn't do
that model i appreciate understand and
believe
is a wonderful idea because it's clearly
the ben and jerry model they cared a lot
about their
community but when ben and jerry wanted
to
grow and become a behemoth in the ice
cream business
they ran into the ultimate problem of
scale
scalability of this and they don't own
it anymore because it was bought by
someone who said well there's a cost of
capital to making ice cream
the cost of protein the cost of
distribution
my question to everybody that pursues
this is
is it sustainable enough that you can
create a
competitive entity that goes beyond
your vision it has to be something that
creates a service or good
in perpetuity for all of your customers
and what i
find very often is people bs themselves
they say to themselves
i'm going to game the system i'm going
to tell everybody that if they buy a
pair of socks from me
i'll give a pair to charity i'll get
lots of free press
the buyers at walmart will want to see
me because i'm doing something good
and i'll actually stay in business even
though my costs are twice as high as my
competitors
and you know what so you've got a
problem with that you've got to well you
know what i
will tell you i have a problem with this
park or whoever is doing that as part of
their business i have a problem with it
because it's [ __ ]
it's not sustainable it doesn't work
those companies
are still calling me up saying i need to
raise more money but don't worry
profitability is right around the corner
no it isn't it isn't the thing to
understand
about business and society is this
last year and part of it comes from
right here in seattle was the largest
amount
of capital given back by entrepreneurs
in the history of the planet earth from
the profits of their successes of their
companies
after the company had paid it back to
the shareholders they turned around
and gave it all back
they didn't break the dna of their
business to do that
they created massive successes in amazon
in microsoft in google in facebook
and then they took the profits and paid
it forward and that's where they did it
they didn't make it a part
exactly
why is it why does it matter why does it
matter whether you uh
are a tom's shoe company very successful
very successful they make
an example of a company that actually
incorporated into their business model
and was able to raise capital and build
it in a way that kept them competitive
and scaled
but what i find is and this is why i
give a big warning sign is
to take the social mission and say it's
the primary mission of the business
and its dna has now been more modified
and has morphed into something else
and make that secondary to the
shareholder the customer and the
employee
that is not a successful model so it's
really it's a question
am i hearing you say it's a question of
the
magnitude of the social mission
so that it it's in its place
versus the real mission of the business
which is to take care of the customer
the shareholder
the employee or is it is it something
different and
you see what i'm saying no i get it but
but you're what you're gonna if i flip
it and i say my
my business's mission is to do good in
the community and
and give shoes that is a very important
mission it's called
charity and there is a very important
aspect of
what every entrepreneur i give the same
perspective every year
but i don't confuse that with the
mission of my businesses
this is the challenge and i'm not scared
to say this
business is war there are
competitors winners and losers it's
binary you either make money or you lose
it
you need to understand that as an
entrepreneur you have to embrace what
that means to you
and understand what it means to society
your job
is to make that business successful it's
to steal market share from your
competitors it's the salt the earth they
used to walk on
it's to make sure you put them out of
business and you achieve success
then and only then after you have got
all of those profits as being a
successful business model you give it
back and you pay it forward
that is the model that's how it works
and that's never going to change
i want to bring up the house lights
because i can well imagine that some of
you in the audience might like
to take a whack at a shark right
so we have mic runners i don't i haven't
been in the car i've been on tv so i
haven't seen some of the earlier
sessions
we've got about 10 minutes before we're
going to break for lunch
uh i would merely ask as you asked
questions
would you mind introducing yourself very
briefly
and just say what you do for a living or
what company you're starting or work for
very quick introduction and please keep
your question
a question and keep it taught go ahead
hi um my name is zach kramer i run a
company called i.t assurance in portland
oregon we do outsourced i.t support that
doesn't suck
uh kevin my question for you is how do
you make difficult decisions you always
seem very certain of yourself and very
certain of the decisions you've made
can you take us through the process you
use to make the hard choices
i listen to my gut it's not scientific
i've learned over time and i think every
entrepreneur should
trust their feelings because i've
learned
every time i don't listen to my gut i
lose money
every time i say to myself no you're
wrong with that i second guess
myself i lose money you have to listen
successful entrepreneurs have a spider
sense i really believe that they know
what's right they know what's wrong
they have to listen to themselves and it
doesn't always work out but the minute
you second guess yourself you're screwed
you really are you're no longer a leader
people that
follow you into dark places have to
trust you
and you have to trust yourself we we had
on
uh one of the prior iconics in chicago
your fellow shark mark cuban one of the
things that was
very interesting that he said and he
said it
um uh a couple of times i've
said basically i've made lots of
mistakes uh
in in my career i said well what do you
do with those mistakes are you trying to
learn from them
and i said do you carry your mistakes
with you and he said no
i cut them off and i try and learn from
them
but i don't let them weigh me down yeah
i agree with them and we talk about that
a lot
the analytics though well because it's
the same as investing i spend a lot of
time investing a lot of capital in
in the public markets and debt markets
globally
you make mistakes it's impossible to
make 100 success in every
stock you buy it's the minute you start
losing you've got to take it behind the
barn and shoot it you have to sell it
and you have to realize i hope i learned
from that mistake but you don't always
i rather invest in entrepreneurs that
have had multiple failures before i meet
them i love
the sting of failure as a motivational
tool
for somebody that wants to succeed
versus somebody that says to me
well i've never run a business this is
my first turbo baster i'm showing it to
you now
and that's to me that person isn't ready
for prime time
i love i love what failure does to your
way of thinking it brings fear into it
and it's great do we have a question
down here
they want a turbo baster actually
hi kevin my name is andrea and i own and
operate outpatient therapy clinics for
children
and my question is about with making
money i'm all for making money it's why
i'm doing it
my entire staff are all people that are
in health services
and so the idea of making profit in
health care to them is a dirty word
and i'd be interested to know how you
would talk to people
that that have that belief that they
should be there just to do good
not to make money how you would address
that interesting question it is an
interesting question you find that also
in education
an area that i was very involved in for
a long time
these two things can be in parallel the
reason is
if you provide great goods and services
by hiring people that are very good at
what they do
and the reason you can do that is you're
growing successful business and you're
basically reinvesting back in people
what i say is to them look people that
are concerned because we were very
focused in my case in math and reading
scores
and many many teachers very good ones in
phonetic reading or whatever
their their their tools are i would try
and hire and they'd say to me well i'm
a little uncomfortable about doing this
for profit because you're making
millions off read a rabbit and i say
yeah i am
the rabbit is a very rich rabbit and the
reason you should do this
is you're going to help hundreds of
thousands of kids around the world
and you're going to help me hire more
people like you to do this good work
and we are going to give back because we
were doing a lot of that
as shareholders into education after we
paid our dividends out
and you're doing it because you're going
to help the next dyslexic child because
i was dyslexic
and the people that helped me they also
were
they had to make money doing it and i'm
so glad that i met them
so the point is you can put both a moral
social educational mission right beside
profit
we have made a big mistake in the last
10 years vilifying capitalism
i'm one of the people that want to take
that back
in i would just say and i don't want to
get into politics here but the last
two administrations were about
redistribution of wealth
and solving for health care and we've
done a masterful job with that
it's now time to focus on what makes
america work
which is business to make it easier to
start a business sustain a business we
get we have to fix our corporate tax
rates
the next president he or she this will
be the primary mandate
it has to happen because we're not
competitive anymore and
these things can always work together
you can do great things
and make money and the two of them can
work hand in hand
let's go back here uh to the aisle there
my name is ed uh i'm a co-founder of
yoga panda which is a startup that helps
people find yoga classes in seattle
and my question is to mr wonderful
chasing opportunity
versus chasing passion
which one do you think is more important
well you know
every entrepreneur i meet is very
passionate that's just part of the
equation i actually
argue that what matters most
is executional skills every
entrepreneur's passion
everybody that's an entrepreneur is
ready to to take that journey and
and go down that road and that's great
but the ones that are still doing it
three years later
have executional skills so that's what i
think matters above everything else i
meet lots of teams i fund lots of
companies
i see lots of failure and lots of
successes the difference is
men and women primarily women these days
that can really execute that set goals
tell you what they are talk to every
three months saying i achieved this goal
or i didn't
and why and to me that's the building
block of a business
there's nothing worse than vision all
day long
vision's easy execution is hard let's go
back
uh there on that side hi my name is john
strafano i'm the ceo of garmentory we're
a startup in seattle we're
the etsy for young luxury so we're a
marketplace um
for young luxury contemporary fashion
100 to 600 items um our business is
growing really well
uh when we talk to venture capitalists
and i talk to a lot of venture
capitalists
um my question specifically for you is
how do how do
excellent entrepreneurs break
preconceived notions that you have
and then give you what they think is
actually the reality so for example
we're in a 40 billion dollar market
people hear
boutiques or contemporary fashion and
they think ah that's a small market but
it's not a small market
so how do you what have you seen from
entrepreneurs that's been really
effective
if you want to successfully raise money
because i've heard pitches from your
space
100 times now and the where they make a
mistake every time is
what we've all learned about building
that i love that space by the way
because
what i find so remarkable about men and
women that are passionate about fashion
they throw caution to the wind on price
and margin they don't give a damn
if they see something they want they'll
kill for it and i think that's fantastic
you find that also
in the marriage business and you find it
in the burial business all three of
which i invested
and so you don't care about price when
you're dead or when you're getting
married
that's great but what you never answer
when you're pitching is the first
question you should answer before you're
even asked it is
you figured out customer acquisition
cost because in fashion
acquiring the customer and making them
loyal has
in most cases 99 of the time is actually
more expensive than the lifetime value
of the customer and so i immediately go
to that and say
what are your customer acquisition costs
and what is the lifetime value even
though your business only been around
for eight months or something
and that's where i find the models
broken because unless you
can find a way to acquire a customer and
the ones that have been successful have
you think of those in the bridal
business for example that sell dresses
rent dresses
and in groomed you know gowns and
everything else they have found a way to
get that that equation nailed down
and anybody in here that's pitching an
online business answer that question
first the first
in your deck after you've explained what
the business does
let the second slide say customer
acquisition costs lifetime value
that's how you're going to get an
investor interested that you've somehow
solved for that
everything else is secondary so if my
cache ltv is 40
how do i change your mind about market
size or some other thing
you don't have to change my mind about
market size that's not my number one
question
my question is sustainability of your
business model i don't care if your
market's 10 billion 1 billion
500 million am i going to get you know
sustainability to get 10 15 share of the
market i'm a quick study on this stuff
i can figure it out in a couple of
minutes whether it's going to work or
not
based on your customer acquisition cost
what do you know that i don't know about
getting a customer
because i've done it in multiple sectors
now i know it works and what doesn't
the reason companies like you know
bottle breacher which makes
they take ordinance bullets and turn
them into wedding gifts
i mean how crazy is that but they know
how to acquire customers and they're
wildly profitable
same with cupcakes same with wedding
gifts
the question is if you talk to sarah who
runs honey fund
all she talks about is customer
acquisition cost that's it
that's 99.9999 of her business challenge
after that she knows what to sell them
but work on that
last question goes to that one matt
aisle hi my name is ahmad from
university of washington
and we're starting a business in virtual
reality education
so my question is you highlighted that
team is the most thing you're interested
you will be investing in what kind of
characteristic or dynamic you look into
the teams before you invest
in a company well that's a great
question a good way to end it
so what i look for is um
teams that augment
or solve for the leader's weakness
because
if you come and tell me you're the ceo
you're the founder you're the largest
shareholder
that you know and you're perfect at
everything i know you're full of crap
that that is so not true great
entrepreneurs know their weaknesses and
surround themselves with solutions
the logistics person the marketing
person the accounting person
the saleswoman the salesman and i'll
tell you guys a little secret here
when i look at new deals existing
companies and i'm being asked to either
fund with debt or equity
the first thing i do is i don't take the
meeting with the ceo
i ask to go and drink good wine with the
man or woman running
sales and i say look you know i'm not
available on that city so i'll pay to
fly her
or him out to new york and i'd like to
just have dinner with them
and often the cfo was trying to broken
the deal says no no i'll come with them
i said no
no no no no i like to meet with the head
of sales
and i it's just kind of a ritual that's
how i work and
good wine i'm talking good wine
and the head of sales and three hours
and i can tell you everything about that
company because the head of sales knows
where this
where things are buried they know where
the problems are with the customer base
they know where the opportunities are
and my point is the ceo
the next meeting is with the ceo and the
cfo and if they know
less than i do about
their company from the sales person
i know who to fire when i get control of
that company and it's not the head of
sales
in my companies there's no cap
on the compensation for the man or woman
that runs sales
ever they're always the highest paid
person
always and so
talk about a team you want to interview
from the sales
down without sales you don't have a
company get to know the sales team
then meet the logistics people then meet
you know
i'll tell you the truth ceos are
fungible you can get a new one anytime
they are the captain and if they can't
lead the ship
you got to swap them out and i i know
that sounds terrible but i help
ceos that are large shareholders get out
of the way of success sometimes
i've done it multiple times now because
they're not the right person
teams team leaders like great
quarterbacks
understand what they're not good at
there's nothing worse than an
arrogant ceo that thinks they're good at
everything i just can't wait to shoot
them
if you like that video wait do you see
my next one
don't forget to click right over here
and subscribe